[Music]
well the role of carrie simmons is
looked at by douglas murray in his
column for this week's magazine he says
that she's increasingly becoming
like an office for the first lady do we
necessarily want to go down
an american route he joins me now along
with kate andrews or economics editor
who's got a bit more sympathy for the
idea
but douglas first of all i mean surely
we what we need is a recognition that
things have moved on that of course
um politicians spouses are going to be
important to them and carry simmons is
always going to be influential
to boris johnson is it so bad to simply
acknowledge the fact
well i suggested the beginning of my
piece that it's not a very good
arrangement in america
that having an office in the east wing
of the white house which is the office
of the first lady
isn't an entirely comfortable fit in the
u.s it makes american politics
less like democracy more like a court in
which
you don't only have the first lady or
perhaps at some point in the future of
the first husband
but all the encumbrances of the first
children and much more
you have first ladies proposing
legislation you had this in the 1990s
with hillary clinton an exceptionally
uncomfortable moment
when the spouse of a president is
proposing legislation
for the country nobody elected her at
that point they did subsequently
uh nobody elected her at that point and
there's something extremely
uncomfortable about this that somebody
should
effectively get power simply by the fact
that
some decades earlier they were fortunate
enough or otherwise to marry somebody
who ended up becoming the president
right but not everybody can be a sort of
silent dennis thatcher i mean
you don't need to give carrie simmons
legislative
powers but surely a bit more formal
support
would have avoided this mess in the
first place and what we're surely seeing
is problems arising from a lack of
support
given to the office of the prime
minister's spouse
or the lack of well she she has had
formal support
she has had a 100 000 pound a year
director of communications paid for
based in downing street to give her
advice as an extraordinary situation to
be in
i don't believe that dennis thatcher
ever benefited from any
such munificence in recent decades in
fact throughout history
the spouses of prime ministers in the
united kingdom have actually
tried to audition to show they do not
have influence
dennis thatcher as you referred to very
successfully portrayed himself as a sort
of silly old buffoon
precisely to go under the radar in this
way sherry blair who is of course an
extremely distinguished and successful
barrister in her own right
was constantly having to demonstrate
during her husband's time in downing
street
that she was not mixing up her
professional and her personal life
and i suggest that is quite as it should
be
we do not have first ladies or first
gentlemen we have not had first
girlfriends before
and it is very desirable for our country
that that remains the case
and kate andrews perhaps britain then is
the model that america should follow and
not
vice versa well douglas is completely
right to point to the tension that the
role has created historically in the
united states
when george washington's wife martha
washington was first dubbed lady
washington
people felt very uncomfortable about
this it it rank of nobility and that was
exactly what america had just
fought to get itself rid of
so the title itself has actually been
contentious uh really going back
all the way in american history but i
would argue that perhaps it's the best
of a bunch of bad options because
in reality i think it's true certainly
true in america but
becoming increasingly true in the uk you
have to have something to do
if you are in one of these positions we
no longer live in a society
where women are just automatically going
to do the domestic job
um and in america we have not yet had a
female president so it's always been a
woman who's been
in in this supportive role and i think
that's become more formalized
and possibly in a positive way and
douglas mentions
hillary care there and i think it's
almost the exception that proves the
rule
hillary care was a disaster it was seen
as a huge
overreach of the first lady when bill
clinton appointed her
to be chair of that health reform task
force and it completely failed it never
properly got off the ground and i think
a large part in that was a feeling
that was not the role of an unelected
far less accountable person
to be taking on if the president wants
to reform health care that's one thing
but if their spouse wants to do it
that's quite another
the other initiatives that we've seen
from first ladies in recent years
are indeed fundamentally rooted in
politics
but they tend to be something that's
more on the sideline that feeds into the
president's agenda and at the end of the
day
the president of course is still
responsible and i think in 2021
um if you are a man or a woman in the
u.s or the uk
supporting the president or prime
minister there's a very real chance that
you've stepped away from your own career
we saw that with michelle obama
we saw that with hillary clinton and
here in the uk you know carrie simons
was
doing her own job she was came up
through the ranks the conservative party
was working for bloomberg
she's somebody who's going to want to be
involved in some capacity
formalizing that i think is a much
better option than what we've seen over
the past few months
where because it is completely informal
it gets very very messy but also
you can't hold her or anybody else to
account in the same way you could
if all of this were formerly on the
record
may i just ask though uh uh
kate if that's your contention how could
this situation be improved
how could the first girlfriend be more
accountable
if she had a larger office with a bigger
spend how would we hold her accountable
well the idea is that what she would be
doing wouldn't be behind the scenes
anymore
it would be public and everybody would
be able to say is this feeding into the
prime minister's agenda
does this feel right is this what the
prime minister was elected to do
and this sideline project has been given
to his fiancee
i think you would have more
accountability there but i think one of
the pro
well it would be formalized what her job
was supposed to be
would be on the record and then if she
were doing things that
weren't in her remit in that position i
think would be much
more easily scrutinized and we'd be able
to call it out much faster i mean one of
the problems we've had
for months now is that when her name is
brought into this you have a lot of
people who say
she shouldn't be brought into this at
all that's sexist that's problematic
she has nothing to do with what happens
in downing street
and we should stop kidding ourselves of
course she has plenty to do
with what's happening in downing street
in america it's far from a perfect
system i completely agree with you
douglas
and it may well cost some taxpayer money
but at least we're not pretending
that the situation isn't what it is it's
on the record it's formalized and you
can
hold people accountable you can
scrutinize it at the moment i almost
think it's too easy to say
she's not involved we should create a
system in which we can talk about her
involvement
and you know be critical of it if
necessary
okay but can i can i ask a brass tax
question in this situation
and let's take an example i given the
piece 2020
uh there is a proposed badger call
because farmers and others in the uk
have a particular problem with badges
carrie simons apparently persuades
her boyfriend her fiancee the prime
minister that the cull should be stopped
and he does stop the cull
now that's against a lot of expert
advice and i'm told that one of the
communities that suffered from this this
decision was the hedgehog community
now as it currently stands uh there is
no accountability
uh for carrie simons for this decision
but i do not
see and i'm yet to be persuaded that
were there a formal
office of the first girlfriend in
downing street there would be any more
accountability
what would we do you can't chuck her out
you can't say to the prime minister i'm
sorry you've got to get a different
first girlfriend you've got to fire this
one
he may want to at some point but we
can't tell him to do that he's not in
our remit as voters
in the in the united kingdom if you want
political power
you've got to stand before the
electorate and offer yourself before the
electorate
there is no other way that is one of the
principles of british democracy it was
one of the principles that drove
our vote to leave the european union
accountability
of the elected to the electorate and the
proposition
that on top of the elected you get
spouses and in time
children and in america we currently
seem to have a sort of informal position
of the
the niece of the vice president i
suggest
if people want power in britain there's
only one way to get it and to wield it
which is to first put yourself before
the public
and see whether they like you or not
[Music]
you